home buyers will be facing a pretty
costly surprise come May 1st a new
federal rule will affect those with good
credit scores making them pay more to
subsidize people with riskier credit
scores it's part of a push by the
federal Housing Finance Agency to try to
make homes more affordable by reducing
the rates for those riskier borrowers
Tom Blanchard with the Nevada
Association of Realtors weighs in saying
it's unfair to those that do have a good
credit
they're incentivizing those with bad
credit which can lead us into having the
same kind of problem that we had back in
2008 when we were giving credit to
anybody
and with that I I think would is rather
dangerous
so home buyers with a credit score of
680 or higher will pay less for example
about forty dollars per month more on a
home loan of let's say four hundred
thousand homeowners who make large down
payments will feel the pain with the
largest fees those new fees will apply
only to those who are buying houses or
refinancing after May 1st